how are you guys feeling right now after
tonight's results
well jenna's shoulder has a hole in it
because i was scraping it while we were
standing there that was not fun at all
super grateful to be here um but you
know being in the bottom too is not fun
scary yeah
but a good reminder that we need to
remind people to vote and nobody is safe
whatsoever whatsoever even depending on
what you're supposed to do
why do you think why do you think that
that was why do you think you were in
the bottom two
this week of all weeks i mean obviously
your guys your scores have been
incredible you're definitely a fan
favorite so it was a little very
shocking
you know honestly i think the world
has a world and we're in that world and
it just has a way of working
and it's
all numbers and there's a lot of people
that vote and there's a lot of amazing
people here i also think maybe people
think that because we have the last
three weeks gotten really high scores
that we'll just sail by yeah and that's
not the case clearly tonight um so yeah
votes matter please oh friends family
loved ones
i think michael you're on mute
wow
my mouth must be really big if you could
tell i was talking hey
um
jenna have you seen that exact thing
happen over the years and and stories uh
that you've heard about the show where
people are doing really well and because
people think oh well they're doing so
well they they must be going through and
then people forget when we see that
happen it usually the next week then
they're not in the bottom two because
their fan base is rallied absolutely i
think we've seen it a lot of times and
you know i'm just grateful that we
weren't the ones going home because i've
also seen that where there's like a
shocking elimination where somebody that
you thought was going to the finals ends
up going home even tonight the miz i
know we it was like terrible being in
the bottom two with miz so it was scary
yeah he's amazing i hope that this is
just a great little like boost for our
fans and it was for us yes you know what
this is great though i feel like both of
us love a challenge and i think if
anything this is going to motivate us
for next week
what are your thoughts on uh janet
jackson week because a lot of people are
going to be introduced to janet jackson
which is sounds crazy but
uh what are your thoughts on uh next
week
i'm excited i'm so excited i mean janet
music has been in my life for a really
long time i think she's cool i think
she's a legend
and i think her music is so danceable
you know obviously queen is my number
one thing so i don't know if it'll top
tonight for me but somehow every week
tops the last so i have a feeling it
will
what can you guys do to actually bring
it you seem to be bringing it more and
more every week and next week it feels
like you have to bring it even more
because of tonight's results
i
i have gotten to know jen really well in
the last eight nine weeks
and i know that i don't know what she's
gonna do but i know she's gonna somehow
come up with a way to make next week's
dance our hardest one yet our most
technique filled one yet and our
craziest but yet controlled one yeah i
know you're gonna push me to like no
other next week and i'm excited for it
here's the thing also we were asked you
know like well what do you think went
wrong nothing went wrong we didn't do
anything wrong she definitely did not do
anything wrong or hasn't she's just been
killing it every week
um but
i think it's gonna just light a fire for
us this week in rehearsals and we're
gonna push absolutely
jojo obviously you've talked a lot about
your confidence growing and we can see
it clearly each week we're getting more
and more have you seen changes like in
yourself and your body and your workout
anything like that like how you how
you've changed the amount of times today
that i've just gotten down and done five
push-ups nose to the floor i mean i've
literally probably done that 20 times
today
and i i've noticed that i used to be
like oh i'm gonna have to do a push-up
oh but i'm like oh five push-ups let's
go and then i do it and i feel like
refreshed and it feels wild
i
i mean look at her can you just see like
the changes in this look at this one
piece ah
i think my brain is just kind of
molded in a good way and i think that
i can see how strong this one has made
me and i can see that i can do a three
minute plank and 20 push-ups and kill it
so therefore it like verifies in my head
like we're pretty strong yeah
every time jen is like all right so
here's what we're gonna do you're just
gonna go like this and lift me and i'm
like okay so what does that mean you're
gonna do and she's like well
what did you guys think of that's in
diet comparison from carrie anne that
was amazing that was i think such a big
compliment for you
um
zendaya i think flourished on the show
and then became who she is now a
freaking icon and so for you to be
compared to that i was like yes please
it's interesting
because and i've actually never told you
about this yet is people my whole life
have been waiting for me to have my like
child star breakout go crazy moment when
there's like always a p a point in time
where a child star goes from being a
child star to
phasing out of that phase of life yeah
and a lot of times they go crazy to
phase out of that time that phase of
life but for me i feel like this is my
transition yeah and i feel like it's
such a good
wholesome
right way of transitioning out of being
a child star and it feels
so good to grow every single day and
learn new things about myself every
single day yeah
can you speak a little bit more a little
bit more to that um you talked about you
know the physical changes that you've
noticed and how you can do
50 million push-ups in a day but what
about like your mind and your emotional
state how have you how have you grown
throughout this process
my mind has changed more than my body
has for sure
um
you know i've learned a lot
i've learned a lot about being happy
i've learned a lot about just yesterday
and the day before not second guessing
myself and being on eggshells
and i learned how stressed i get when i
think jen's mad at me
i'm never mad at her
but i got really stressed that she
learned it only made my day go even
further downhill
literally wasn't at all i've learned a
lot about my mind and it's it's growing
and it's changing
and i think the biggest way that it has
is i've become more open-minded about
myself i've always been open-minded
about others
but i think i've been close-minded with
myself and i think it's cool that i'm
finally a little open-minded
i love that well congratulations you
guys thank you so much